dans ce film, je présente de
nouveaux personnages extrêmement importants plutôt qui,
comme Silver Bay, votre frère et votre sœur,
il est rapide et rapide et anxieux et
elle est ancrée et réfléchie Les jumeaux Wanda et
Pietro Maximoff sont orphelins à 10 ans
lorsqu'un obus effondre leur
immeuble, ils n'en ont qu'un  un autre c'est un
peu juste eux contre le monde
est très rapide aussi rapide presque aussi rapide
qu'une balle il est rapide tout est
colérique tout le monde va si lentement pour lui
n'a pas vu ceux venir et puis Scarlet
Witch tu as la télékinésie elle peut déplacer des
choses et  elle peut entrer dans votre tête
pour que toutes vos pires peurs ou doutes
viennent au premier plan les filles maximov où pouvez-
vous commencer ce qui est si intéressant pour moi, c'est à
quel point elle est connectée et à quel point
elle est ancrée avec l'univers et combien de
pouvoir elle a sans s'en rendre compte  elle
dérange tous les Avengers à un
point tel qu'ils doivent aller quelque part
et revenir en tant qu'unité, comment comptez-vous
les battre ensemble
?  Il nous faut un certain temps pour
comprendre à qui on peut faire confiance et à qui
on ne peut pas
et qui fait partie de notre équipe et qui ne l'est pas